well two games that people love topgolf
and angry birds rocky is live at topgolf
to show us how they have partnered up
with some
fun family adventures tell us more about
this rocky
yes mercedes okay who doesn't love top
golf and who doesn't love angry birds
okay it's been
around for years it's super popular and
they've partnered together
to create a new game of tough golf
that's right and this is no this is no
you know normal thing okay when i when i
hit the ball earlier i was really
excited
she was really excited so she's gonna
explain kim's gonna explain how to play
the game
yes so i think my favorite part of this
game is you can pick your skill level
because i'm not good so i'm gonna be a
beginner guessing so we're gonna go as a
beginner
and then uh we'll start with some
impeccable morning so you get to choose
from three different
chapters so we'll go ahead and plugable
morning you know
especially on a monday heck yeah
impeccable afternoon we'll call it yeah
impeccable afternoon
so what you're gonna do is you're going
to come up here and you're going to
dispense the ball
you're going to you know the normal
topgolf stuff you dispense the ball like
this
absolutely and if you look at the top
tracer screen you'll be able to see
the castle that you're trying to knock
down oh okay so okay so this is
the display and basically you're trying
i'm trying to
go for the tnt in the middle right so
you want the tnt to explode but you'll
see that the red targets are right there
at the bottom so you know what you're
aiming for
okay you're gonna want to try and hit
between those red targets okay so while
i try and get my life together over here
explain how this is socially distant and
safe for people yeah so the
the good thing about this is we have t
is 11 feet apart
naturally but then we also separated the
bays with dividers
that was so good that's going to go
right down the middle i think
oh no come on
[Applause]
and the tnt exploded so you get three
chances to knock it down so you get two
more to knock down the whole
castle okay i'm in this angry birds this
angry birds game is very fun
coming up in the four o'clock we're
gonna head downstairs to play with some
families and learn about the
angry bird dance oh yeah angry all right
and don't forget the 25
off local discount here at topgolf i'll
send it back to you guys
nice job okay nice job rocky yeah we'll
check back in with you during the 4pm
newscast
i love the excitement of her voice when
she knocked it down it was awesome